Now when you're looking down and it's
an utter whiteout and you're looking at
your compass and you're
dragging this shit behind you,
like are you doing anything in your mind?
Are you like singing songs?
Are you, what are you doing?
Um,
there's a couple of different things,
but really what ended up happening is I
started to be able to trigger these flow
states. So, you know,
as a lifelong professional athlete
through different capacities in my life,
you know, I've tapped into that. You know,
I was a swimmer when I was a little kid,
so swimming laps in a pool,
sometimes I would like kind of just
happen to this like timeless space where,
you know, maybe 30 minutes would go by
in, in two minutes or something like that.
But I never really knew how I got
there. Just, it's sometimes tap into it,
sometimes not, you know, the zone flow,
state, whatever you want to call that.
But in Antarctica,
I went in with this sort of attention
about intention of exploring that space in
my mind.
And so as I got more and more into
these wideouts outs into these compass,
in staring at this compass,
staring at this expansive landscape,
I started to find ways to actually
trigger that flow state in my mind.
So it got to the point where I
could for several days at a time,
be in this deep flow state. So, you know,
my day was about 17 hours every day
between getting up, boiling my water,
getting out of my tent, and those
crazy conditions, packing my sled,
dragging it for 13 hours,
setting my tent back up in these storms.
But I got into this sort of sequence
of being so present with each step,
each next sequence that it ended up
being in this really timeless spaceless
place in my mind of true high-performance
that was almost like the most deepest,
peaceful, meditative state that
I can possibly imagine. It was.
It was very profound and beautiful,
uh, to get there in my mind. Wow.
No.
Are you boiling this water in your tent?
Yeah. So my Ted Boyle. Yeah. So kind of a
slightly different white gas fuels stove.
So, not the canisters
where you could throw away,
but like gas that you could refill
the stove but a stove with fuel. Um,
basically the way my tent was, you
saw the outer layer, the tent there.
There's actually an inner part that's a
tent so that there's a vestibule where
basically there's snow inside the
doorway but not outside, outside.
So I would shovel that snow from inside
of the tent vestibule into my pot and be
able to melt the water that way.
Um,
I drank about six liters of
water every single day, um,
when I was out there, which no, it's
just a lot of snow, a lot of antiques,
a few hours to melt that.
But people don't realize this in order
cause actually the largest desert in the
world. Um, so it's actually very dry. It
doesn't snow very often, but when it does,
of course never melt in the South
Pole was at 9,000, 300 feet.
So not only am I in this desert,
but I'm at altitude doing this thing.
So
did you train it out to two? Did you use
like one of those tents to sleep in or,
yeah, so there's a, this gym that Mike
and I train out of, it's called evolution,
healthcare and fitness in Portland.
Um,
they actually have an altitude room
there so that it's not even a tent,
but they actually have a full, a
full room where you can, you know,
got rowing machines.
It's got treadmills.
It's got all that stimulated
up to about 14,000 fees.
It's about 400 square feet, high
ceilings, big. I mean, it's not like cute,
but it's a big enough. Yeah,
it's like a proper room.
I've been in some of those tents before
when I was racing triathlon many years
ago, a lot of people were
starting to sleep in those tents,
but black people have a hard time and
then they get warm and stuff like that.
I know a lot of fighters use them
as well. Um, but, uh, but yeah,
it was pretty cool to have a full
room that you can actually, you know,
be in and move in properly,
um,
for just simulate some of the
high intensity stuff. Yeah.
And so it would take you hours
every day to make your water? Yeah,
I would say I was boiling water for
about three, four hours per day.
So about an hour or two in the morning,
hour or two in the evening. Uh,
it takes a lot of energy to boil, you
know, frozen snow when it's that cold out.
Um,
she had to carry to carry a lot of fuel.
That was the other really
heavy composed sled.
It's like hundreds of hours of
fuel. Yeah. So I took about, uh,
17 liters of fuel. So that's what, six
gallons or something like that. Oh, wow.
How'd you know that that
was going to be enough? Uh,
I did some practicing
beforehand. Um, I, I,
in 2016 I did another world record project
where I climbed the tallest mountain
on each of the seven continents,
seven summits,
as well as when to the
north and South Pole,
but much smaller polar expeditions a week,
uh,
basically crossing the
last degree of latitude.
And so when those expeditions Alpha was
on Everest during that time to not only
et Cetera, all of that in 139 days, um,
but I did that and that kind
of helped me get a sense of it.
But honestly it was also best
guess based on talking to people,
different experts in the field,
you know, diving into that.
But you never know is it going
to be enough or too little?
I'm here on the side of too
much. When you, when, when
you finally got to the end,
how much did you have left? So my final
push, I actually, I woke up on uh,
the morning of Christmas Eve 24th of
December this past year and it looked,
I was 77 miles from the finish
and I've been going at that point,
at the beginning of the trip I was
only going nine, 10 miles per day.
Towards the end I started going on
about 20, 25 miles per day. So I said,
you know what, like I'm about three
days out. And then I thought to myself,
maybe if I could push really hard these
next two days, I could do it in two days,
like two 15 plus hour days.
Like really get into it and started
looking at my fuel and food supplies and
like they were pretty low. I had had
enough fuel, a few, a few liters of fuel,
but I actually only had
about a day or two of food,
like real substantial food left.
Um,
and so I woke up and I was like,
all right, let's go for this.
And in the actually deepest
talk about flow states,
that was the deepest flow state of my
life. I woke up in one hour in that day,
it's Christmas morning now I wake up
and I'm just locked in and I just came.
I didn't tell anyone back home,
didn't tell my wife who was tracking me.
They had this gps tracker
where they could follow me.
But I was just in my mind I was like,
you know what? Not not three days,
not two days.
I'm going straight for it.
And so I did a final 32 hour continuous
push on day 54 77 miles straight,
drag in my sled all the way to get to
the finish line in one continuous push.
No music, no nothing. Just like in my
head in this, in this crazy flow state of,
of, of, I don't know, high performance.
Um, and it was, it was like,
it was a crazy final push to get there,
but a made it right before the
food and fuel ran out. Oh my God.
And then there's, there's no
one there of course. Right.
You crossed the finish line.
You're like, done this.
No one in the world has ever
done this. Applause. Nope. Zero.
And so what do you do when you get to the
end? You said, hey, I'm done. Come get me.
Yeah. Yeah. How long does it
take for them to come get you?
It took me a week to
get out of Antarctica.
Totally took actually me four
days to get out of there. Um,
but there's a crazy
other component to this,
which is no one in the world had ever
done this before. And like I said,
a few really talented people.
Some of the best explorers in the world
had tried recently. One guy died. Um,
and it just so happened there's a really
specific season when you can attempt
this. But another guy was attempting
this at the exact same time as me.
I'm a British, a British guy who's a
equivalent of a navy seal, you know,
British special forces,
the living most experienced
guy in Antarctica is actually
pulled 3000 plus miles
and an article now on various expeditions.
And so we got dropped off one mile away
from each other to begin this thing.
And um,
obviously I was the first,
I did win this race head to head and at
the finish line I waited for him for a
few days cause I wanted to congratulate
him cause he did ultimately finished.
But you can only imagine I would vote.
Going back to that first hour, I was like,
it's impossible. It was also like, it's
impossible. And both the, by the way,
this navy seal dude who knows more
about Antarctica, me, he's often going,
I can see him in the distance just
like leaving me in the dust. Um,
but fortunately after day six
I caught up to him, you know,
I waved to him in this weird
like passing of the torch moment.
Like I was passing him and then I never
saw him again until I finished and I
finished about a 70 miles ahead of him,
about two and a half days ahead of them.
That's going to suck
for him. Imagines, look,
I got this mother Fucker, I brought
it home for America, man. You know,
appreciate that. We all will
appreciate that, but still,
that's going suck for him.
Yeah.
So I actually,
even though I finished in the first
thing I could have kind of wanted to do,
I haven't had, I haven't
had a shower. I haven't,
I actually to save weight so I could
get as much food and fuel with my sled.
I brought no extra clothes,
no extra pair of underwear,
like literally no extra pair of
underwear, no prepared. So I grow.
Where are you shitting out there?
Everyone wants to know this,
so let's just get it all the
table. Thank you for asking. Um,
I basically, I described that vestibule
situation. So one side I cook in, right?
If the wind is calm, I get out of
my tent, dig a hole and you know,
go shit in a whole basically. But when
it's real windy, like those storms,
I just watch like you're going to get
frost bite if you try to, you know,
bend over, pull your pants
down when it's minus 80 hours.
So in the vestibule of my tent,
not the side I'm cooking on,
but the other side where I'm still
inside covered, I dig a hole in there.
That was my morning routine.
Get up at 6:00 AM,
start boiling my water at one side
of my tent and it's not glamorous.
It's not a pretty thing at debate.
Actually, to me, this is very cool,
but also not glamorous. Um, within one
degree of latitude of the south pole.
So the last degree of latitude at 89
degrees to south poles at 90 degrees,
it's basically 69 miles or 60 nautical
miles circumference around the south pole.
Antarctica being as pristine as it is,
they have all these laws about
environmental conservation,
which to me is amazing.
Being someone who loves and is
a great steward of the land,
they actually say you can't even leave
your human waste in holes here even
though there's nobody out there.
They're like,
we want this to be completely
protected area. And so yes,
usually my sled was getting lighter
most of the time cause I was eating food
everyday and burning fuel.
But in that last degree of latitude
to the south pole and crossing it,
I was shitting in a bag,
wrapping it up and putting it in my
sled and having to carry it with me. So,
um, yeah. Wow. It shows discipline.
She was something a lot of people have
been like, hey yeah, put it in a book.
Fuck you crazy assholes.
One's up there.
Who cares if I take a shit up there?
It was tempting, but you know,
so I grew up in the going out in the
outdoors and just is leave no trace
principle that I, you know, I really
love. And in particularly Antarctica,
one of the things about Antarctica,
it's one of those places where I imagine
you've traveled far and wide and your
life and there's some few places,
at least in my mind, where you just,
you can't put it into words until
you've stepped off there. And for me,
this was my second time and an
article on both times. You know,
this big cargo ship basically
lands you on the continent.
Then you get into smaller plan to get
dropped off to where I needed to start on
the edge of the continent.
But both times stepping off the plane,
I'm just shit eating grin ear to ear on
my face because I just am like, Whoa,
what is this place? Even the second
time seeing it, I felt that I'd like,
my cheeks were sore
because I was just smiling.
So big of just the pristine beauty,
the blank canvas. The amine,
you look out on the land and like human
footprints haven't touched 98% of the
continents, something like that. I mean,
it's untouched and so shitting in a bag,
if I had to do that to do my
part, to keep it that way, uh,
I wasn't shit. Did you drag, uh,
at the end it was about three.
You reuse the bags.
One per day for at that section is about
120 miles. It took me, I don't know,
a week or so to cover that
distance. So, um, yeah, added,
added weight to my sled rather
than subtracting during.
That was the middle part of the journey.
Red around the 30th and 40th day.